[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mardi 4 avril voici le programme de
ce soir ce matin le ministre de la
Justice
Eric Dupont-Moretti était à la prison de
Bois-d'Arcy accompagnée de nombreux
chefs d'entreprises le ministre souhaite
faire travailler davantage de
prisonniers le but limiter le taux de
récidive lorsqu’un détenu à purger sa
peine cette visite du garde des sceaux
vient se heurter à l'action en justice
de l'Observatoire international des
prisons et de plusieurs associations qui
dénoncent des conditions d'incarcération
du centre pénitentiaire de Bois-d'Arcy
on fait le point dans cette émission
selon le ministère du travail depuis
2021 et la crise sanitaire l'état de
santé psychique des travailleurs s'est
fortement dégradé charge de travail
relation avec le management ou encore
quête de sens pour aborder et
sensibiliser sur la souffrance au
travail une yvelinoise a écrit un roman
policier intitulé quand l'horreur est il
est inspiré de faits réel l'auteur
Françoise François et psychologue et a
fondé la maison souffrance et travail 78
elle est notre invité on y va nous on y
a tous déjà mis les pieds quand on était
petit le parc France Miniature à
Élancourt rouvre ses portes le 8 avril à
l'occasion du weekend de Pâques le site
vous invite à participer à un monumental
jeu de piste l'événement invite à
découvrir ou redécouvrir d'une manière
ludique les célèbres monuments français
en miniature comme la Tour Eiffel ou le
château de Versailles nous en parlerons
avec Marianne edwyre responsable de la
communication pour France Miniature et
en plateau ce soir avec moi Alain Cissé
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes le
directeur général du groupe pro engin
situé à Saint-Cyr l'école et vous étiez
ce matin à la visite d'Eric
Dupond-Moretti le ministre de la Justice
à la prison de Bois-d'Arcy quelle était
le but de cette visite ce matin le but
de cette visite était de lancer sa
semaine de sur une tournée
en France sur le travail en milieu
carcéral
qui doit permettre effectivement c'est
un ils ont un objectif très ambitieux
mais je pense qui est atteignable c'est
de permettre un maximum de détenus de
pouvoir travailler au sein de la de la
maison d'arrêt ou de la prison pour ceux
qui sont un quart de série on centrale
et de là de se faire un petit peu de
pécule bon pour les aider à leur sortie
mais aussi pour payer leurs dettes
puisque forcément il y a des dettes à
payer en sortant et donc on en parlera
un peu plus en détail dans quelques
instants avec nous également Françoise
François bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes
psychologue à la maison souffrance et
travail 78 situé à Poissy donc vous êtes
également la fondatrice et vous venez
d'écrire un roman policier quand
l'horreur est humaine cela raconte
l'histoire d'Éléonore qui est
psychologue du travail dans la maison
souffrance et travail et alors Éléonore
est empoisonné et sa fille va essayer de
démener l'enquête est-ce que vous pouvez
nous pitcher un peu votre livre faire un
petit résumé en quelques secondes
c'est un roman policier vous l'avez dit
où effectivement jusqu'au bout on ne
saura pas qui a tenter d'éliminer la
psychologue psychologue qui est dans le
coma puisque on a tenté de l'empoisonner
et dans le coma il va se passer quelque
chose pour elle elle va revivre une
autre consultation celle de patience qui
se sont suicidés ou impatient qui a été
assassiné par sa secrétaire et donc elle
va avoir des explications et elle va
avoir des messages à faire passer quand
elle reviendra voilà si elle revient
voilà et
par ailleurs voilà sa fille qui est
officier de police mène l'enquête mais
une enquête qui n'est pas officielle
puisque c'est sa mère qui a été
empoisonnée et le compagnon de sa fille
qui lui est sur l'affaire et qui qui
n'est pas connu pour être le compagnon
de sa fille va mener l'enquête jusqu'au
bout et donc on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler un peu plus tard dans cette
émission des histoires dramatiques qui
se du coup dans le cadre du travail à
nos côtés également Marianne edwire
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes
responsable de la communication pour le
parc France Miniature située à Élancourt
le parc rooft ce samedi 8 avril tout est
prêt c'est presque prêt on va exploiter
les tout derniers jours qu'il nous reste
pour être prêt samedi matin dès 10h pour
accueillir nos premiers visiteurs de la
saison 2023 les conditions en météo sont
plutôt idéales donc on est assez
confiant et puis on réserve des
surprises avec ce week-end d'ouverture
sur la thématique de Pâques oui on
pourra faire le point sur les animations
à venir tout à l'heure et enfin avec
nous un plateau une journaliste de la
rédaction de TV 78 c'est une Charles
bonsoir bonsoir alors avec vous tout à
l'heure on fera le point sur les
informations à retenir dans les Yvelines
dans cette émission également la remise
du prix du livre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines une soirée
humoristique 100% 50 chinoise pour
mettre en avant en des talents locaux et
puis comme chaque mardi les insolites de
Véronique ithurbit ses informations
originales qui vous ont peut-être
échappé dans les Yvelines mais avant
tout ça je vous propose de jeter un coup
d'oeil à la météo de demain
le soleil s'impose dans les Yvelines
demain matin le ciel sera dégagé sur
l'ensemble du département au nez de au
niveau des températures il fera froid
compter 2 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie ou
dans et Rambouillet et 3 degrés à
Versailles alors écoutez bien le dicton
en avril ne te découvre pas d'un fil
dans l'après-midi le soleil continuera
de briller mais les températures
resteront fraîches il fera 12 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles et 13
degrés à ou dans et Rambouillet et
demain nous fêterons la sainte Irène le
point maintenant sur l'actualité on en
parlait en début d'émission si la prison
de Bois-d'Arcy a récemment fait la une
en raison d'une requête en justice pour
ses conditions de détention elle fait
parler d'elle aujourd'hui en raison de
la visite ce matin du ministre de la
Justice
Eric Dupont-Moretti s'est rendu au
centre pénitentiaire accompagné de
nombreux chefs d'entreprise pour
valoriser le travail en prison les
détails avec Patrick Jacques de dixmuth
et Gabriel Gonthier le ministre de la
Justice en visite à la prison de
Bois-d'Arcy fervent défenseur du travail
en prison
Eric Dupond-Moretti est venu présenter
le contrat d'emploi pénitentiaire entrée
en vigueur en début d'année je contrat
il est utile pour le détenu qui se forme
et qui sort de l'établissement
pénitentiaire avec une expérience
professionnelle
ce contrat il est utile pour l'ensemble
de notre société parce que mon obsession
c'est la lutte acharnée sans répit
contre la récidive et enfin ce contrat
grâce à la rémunération permet
l'indignisation des victimes avec ce
contrat les détenus sont rémunérés 45%
du SMIC un engagement gagnant-gagnant
pour le détenu et l'entreprise où chacun
y trouve son intérêt je viens aussi pour
donner une chance un certain nombre de
gens qui ont besoin qui ont envie de se
réinsérer de leur offrir une deuxième
chance donc de leur faire un emploi de
les former les embarquer dans une
nouvelle aventure pour ce patron
versaillé dont l'entreprise travaille
exclusivement avec le système carcéral
le travail se fait directement entre les
murs de la prison on travaille pour
l'industrie automobile aéronautique
cosmétique les imprimeurs on fait de la
sous-traitance voilà on fait de
l'emballage du conditionnement des
petites tâches si aujourd'hui la France
compte 31% de détenus travailleurs
l'objectif du ministère serait à terme
d'attendre les 50%
et parmi les 60 chefs d'entreprises
présents à cette visite du ministre de
la Justice à l'incissé alors je le
répète vous êtes le directeur général du
groupe pro engin situé à
Saint-Cyr-l'École alors prends un jeun
en quelques mots fabrique des détecteurs
chimiques et biologiques à destination
des civile aussi de l'armée et donc vous
possédez le label peps produit en prison
depuis l'année dernière c'est quoi
exactement ce label ce label pep's ça
repose le fait que une partie de nos
produits sont fabriqués en prison en
milieu carcéral
et donc pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
décidé de soutenir l'emploi en milieu
carcéral notre volonté de soutenir
l'emploi en milieu carcéral il y a
plusieurs objectifs 1 c'est ça fait
partie de notre engagement parce que on
croit à la réinsertion des gens par le
travail et aussi pour le travail
donc dans certains cas ça leur permet
aussi de se former donc là derrière
quand il sorte il y a une vraie chance
d'avoir un emploi enfin en tout du moins
on espère qu'on augmente leur chance de
renouer avec l'emploi
et après en fait moi j'ai eu plusieurs
expériences avec le milieu carcéral il y
a une quinzaine d'années au cours d'une
réunion Medef sur le bassin du 78
j'avais eu l'occasion de d'assister à
une présentation du travail en milieu
carcéral au sein de justement de
Bois-d'Arcy et puis là bon voilà c'est
resté là après j'ai travaillé avec la
maison d'arrêt des femmes de Versailles
puis bon pour diverses raisons parce que
bon travail avec les femmes en milieu
carcérale c'est un tout petit peu plus
compliqué parce que moi j'ai jamais à
l'époque surtout essentiellement une
population d'hommes qui travaillait chez
nous et donc il fallait que quelqu'un se
désigne pour aller former ces femmes à
nos métiers or une femme incarcérée
formée par un homme ça a été rapidement
compliqué donc dès lors on l'a compris
on a eu une opératrice qui s'était
portée volontaire sauf qu'à un moment
donné elle a fait valoir ses droits à la
retraite bien méritée et elle est partie
donc là on s'est retrouvé un petit peu
embêté donc on a décidé d'arrêter pour
cette raison et en 2019
confronté depuis nombreux mois à la
difficulté de recruter sur le bassin
local des Yvelines puisque nous notre
établissement est à Saint-Cyr-l'École
je me suis souvenu de cette possibilité
d'ouvrir un atelier donc j'ai recontacté
les services pénitentiaires et c'est
comme ça que je suis rentré en contact à
nouveau avec là le directeur de
Bois-d'Arcy et ensemble après quelques
réunions de travail on a décidé de
réouvrir un atelier ou aujourd'hui et
depuis février 2020 on a environ une
dizaine de détenus qui travaillent
quotidiennement pour notre activité et
alors après sur cette sur ces détenus à
ce jour il y en a deux qui ont intégré
l'entreprise
une fois qu'ils ont été libérés
dans ces entreprises qui décident de
d'embaucher des détenus ça reste
financier puisque il y a moins de
charges patronales le salaire on
l'entend dans le reportage est à 45% du
SMIC c'est un avantage non négligeable
pour vous
c'est vrai je vais pas le nier mais par
contre c'est vrai que nous installons
aussi quand on ouvre un atelier c'est
notre matériel qu'on installe on fournit
absolument tout la maison d'arrêt met à
notre disposition un local et après nous
on amène tout le reste et alors comment
ça se passe concrètement quels sont les
tâches qui leur sont assignées quels
sont les missions on a essayé de alors
l'avantage de du travail en milieu
carcéral c'est qu'on a des gens qui sont
extrêmement compétents on a des gens qui
sont pas formés mais on a aussi des gens
qui sont extrêmement compétents donc
cela se prennent au jeu et forme leur
collègues si je peux dire leur code
détenu
et en fait on leur confie des missions
bien évidemment nous on a une grosse
partie de notre job qui consiste en fait
à assembler un certain nombre de pièces
donc ça ils peuvent le faire moyennant
parce qu'on n'a pas de machine c'est
essentiellement des assemblages manuels
avec des tournevis avec des avec des
petits outils qui ne nécessitent pas un
investissement très lourd
on les recruter j'ai envie de dire
est-ce qu'il y a des entretiens
d'embauche des formations comme dans
tout recrutement il y a des entretiens
d'embauche en fait le responsable des
ateliers se met en lien avec notre
directeur de prod qui qui lui il va à
peu près deux fois par semaine il est
sur place il y va une heure deux heures
il va amener le travail à faire il
récupère après le travail qui a été fait
précédemment entre deux et contrôles
et ils forment parce que forcément de
temps en temps il y a des il y a des
petits compléments de formation à
apporter surtout quand il y a des
nouveaux qui arrivent qui rejoignent qui
rejoignent l'équipe
de ce plateau de ce concept Marianne et
de Vire est-ce que ça pourrait être
quelque chose envisagé par le parc
France Miniature de recruter de
travailler avec des détenus ou pas du
tout ça pourrait l'être et c'est amusant
parce qu'on en a parlé ce matin avec la
direction on fait face comme beaucoup je
pense à des difficultés de recrutement
alors après on a un métier qui est
peut-être un peu plus difficile à
adapter puisque nous on recherche
surtout des gens qui vont faire de
l'accueil de la restauration des
missions sur site mais du coup on y
réfléchissait en sortie de en sortie de
détention c'est vraiment un sujet qu'on
a évoqué ce matin donc oui c'est quelque
chose qui peut être réfléchi et qui qui
va aussi dans le sens d'un engagement et
des valeurs qu'on veut porter dans une
entreprise surtout alors juste une
dernière question
Eric Dupont Moretti a déclaré qu'un
détenu qui travaille c'est un détenu que
c'est réinsère avec 43% de moins de
risque de récidive c'est un chiffre
important c'est un pas important pour la
réinsertion selon vous à l'incissique
pour moi la réinsertion c'est c'est une
des clés qui doit leur permettre de
pouvoir réussir et bon je vais dire
après voilà on est aussi dans la dans
l'acceptation d'une erreur de parcours
ça peut arriver à tout le monde et bien
merci beaucoup Alain juste une petite un
petit point quand même juste pour
préciser grâce à notre notre ouverture
de d'atelier en prison alors rapidement
la période de crise sanitaire certains
noms de nos sous-traitants ont dû fermer
pour des raisons de confinement et nous
on a pu maintenir notre activité grâce
aux travaux de la maison d'arrêt et bien
merci beaucoup Alain Cissé d'avoir
accepté notre invitation on fait le
point maintenant sur les autres
actualités du jour à retenir dans les
Yvelines
et c'est avec vous Céline Charle on
commence ces informations du jour avec
la nouvelle gare de Mantes-la-Jolie qui
a été inauguré ce matin et oui Mathilde
alors petite précision cette gare
implantée place du 8 mai 1945 existait
déjà avec le passage des trains des
lignes NRJ et du TER on parle ici de
nouvelles gares car elle a fait peau
neuve de gros travaux de modernisation
ont été menées depuis 2018 ce matin
c'est le bâtiment voyageur Nord qui a
été inauguré en présence des différents
partenaires qui ont participé à ce
chantier d'un montant de 35 millions
d'euros une transformation dans le but
d'accueillir les futurs voyageurs du
projet EOL se prolongement de 55 km du
RER E vers l'ouest de l'Île-de-France
avec pour terminus Mantes-la-Jolie la
gare accueillera à terme près de 40 000
voyageurs par jour on écoute ses propos
ses propos collectés par Grégory canalet
puisqu'on a carrément reconstruit les
bâtiments voyageurs donc ce qu'on voit
derrière nous c'est le bâtiment voyageur
historique on a gardé que les façades
pour garder une trace de un bâtiment qui
était emblématique il datait du début du
20e siècle de l'arrivée du chemin de fer
à menthe et on l'a agrandi modernisé
pour permettre d'intégrer l'ensemble des
services qui sont maintenant
indispensables à une guerre de nouvelle
générations dans le nouveau plan
d'aménagement de l'Île-de-France nous
avons mis menthe comme une nouvelle
centralité pour faire ça ça veut dire
qu'il faut absolument et bien qu'on ait
des transports qui soient à la hauteur
et ce projet hall qui va desservir toute
la vallée de la scène c'est beaucoup
plus qu'un projet de transport c'est un
projet de revitalisation de l'ensemble
de la vallée de la scène de nouvelles
attractivité de réindustrialisation
aussi c'est la concrétisation et ça sera
la concrétisation pour tous les
habitants du Montois que oui et haul
c'est pas le monstre du Loch Ness c'est
pas ce dont on parle et qu'on ne voit
jamais et all est en train d'arriver
après ce sont des infrastructures qui
nécessitent des travaux importants donc
des mobilisations de financement
considérables donc ça se fait pas en
deux coups de cuillère à pot pour parler
très également mais c'est vraiment bien
engagé
alors reste maintenant à accueillir les
trains de la ligne c'est quand même le
plus le principal après de multiples
retards la fin du prolongement du RER E
est annoncé pour fin 2026 un projet qui
a déraillé financièrement initialement
budgétaire à 3,7 milliards d'euros le
coût de ce chantier phaoni qui est
estimé désormais à 5,4 milliards d'euros
autre information du jour l'école 2600
dédiée à la cybersécurité à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux annonce une levée
de fonds à 6 millions d'euros grâce à
plusieurs investisseurs l'école Saint
cantinoise va lancer une nouvelle offre
de formation dédiée de la cybersécurité
cette offre permettra aux apprenants de
se former ou d'approfondir leurs
connaissances tout au long de leur
parcours professionnel elle se fera au
moyen d'une plateforme en ligne par ce
biais à l'école souhaite former 10000
personnes en France d'ici 2030 et ce
matin à Poissy les commerçants ont pu
échanger avec la chambre des commerces
et de l'industrie de Versailles Yvelines
tout à fait l'opération s'appelle gilet
bleu le président de la CCI Versailles
Yvelines Guillaume Kerrou et le préfet
des Yvelines Ronan Lepage se sont rendus
au centre ville de Poissy ce mardi
accompagné de Samira Tafa mer adjointe à
l'emploi ils ont rencontré plusieurs
commerçants pour échanger sur leurs
besoins en termes par exemple de
transition numérique d'économie
d'énergie ou encore de recrutement
l'objectif était ensuite de trouver des
solutions et enfin un mot de football
très mauvaise opération pour Versailles
dans le championnat de National et ce
lundi les joueurs de la cité royale se
sont inclinés sur leur pelouse un but à
zéro contre l'équipe de Châteauroux une
contre performance qui a des
conséquences au classement les
Versailles sont désormais cinquième avec
quatre points de retard sur le leader
Martigues la montée en Ligue 2 semble
s'éloigner merci beaucoup Céline Charles
pour toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
information ou une image qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news allez
on ouvre maintenant une grande page
culture dans ce 7 8
[Musique]
et donc on commence avec de la
littérature avec un livre qui aborde le
thème de la souffrance au travail selon
le ministère du travail depuis le
covid-19 l'état de santé psychique des
travailleurs c'est fortement dégradé
charge de travail relation avec le
management ou encore quête de sens des
sujets dont Françoise François à
l'habitude de traiter en tant que
psychologue et fondatrice de la maison
souffrance et travail 78 et pour
sensibiliser sur ce sujet elle a écrit
un roman policier intitulé quand
l'horreur est humaine il est inspiré de
fait réel et Françoise François est avec
nous pour en parler le roman commence
fort tout de suite on est plongé dans le
coeur du sujet et Léonore et psychologue
dans la dans cette maison souffrance et
travail et alors elle est empoisonnée on
le disait en début d'émission alors on
suit un petit peu sa fille Jeanne qui
est policière et qui essaye de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé
ce roman je le disais il est inspiré de
deux faits réels alors qu'est-ce
matériel qu'est-ce qui n'est pas réel et
ce que c'est inspiré d'une histoire
d'une de vos collègues de vous qu'est-ce
qui s'est vraiment passé
tout ce qui le lisent posent la même
question en fait
non je n'ai pas été empoisonné voilà
mais rassuré en même temps l'activité
que je fais enfin que nous faisons parce
qu'on est quand même une dizaine de
personnes dans cette maison
oui on ne se fait pas que des amis dans
ce milieu là donc ça aurait pu être
voilà mais ça n'a pas été alors
j'insiste parce qu'on m'a envoyé du thé
en précisant que ça n'était pas
empoisonné on m'a fait pour comprendre
du coup faudrait à lire le livre il faut
lire le livre et pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez décidé d'écrire sur ce sujet
là en particulier c'était un besoin
d'évacuer de ou de sensibiliser alors
évacuer pas du tout non sensibiliser
plutôt
sensibiliser parce que la souffrance au
travail reste quand même aujourd'hui
même si on en parle ça démocratise un
tout petit peu mais c'est pas encore le
sujet du jour pour les instances
voilà et
en parler c'était aussi mettre un peu de
lumière sur cette maison souffrance et
travail
qui n'a pas de subvention d'État en fait
elle peut vivre grâce au travail des
psychologues en interne voilà et
elle est debout en fait depuis
maintenant 10 ans
et parler un peu de notre métier parce
que en fait c'est aussi ça ça permet de
mettre en visibilité le travail que l'on
fait ça démocratise aussi un petit peu
ça ça des diabolise un petit peu aussi
voilà donc on travaille effectivement en
consultation de face à face avec tous
types de salariés c'est des policiers
c'est des gendarmes c'est des médecins
c'est des soignants c'est des gens du
privé public donc ça nous oblige à nous
de savoir naviguer entre le droit public
et le droit privé
ça nous oblige également à comprendre
les processus en œuvre les organisations
voilà ça nous permet aussi d'aller en
entreprise parce qu'on est sollicité par
des chefs d'entreprise
voilà pour régler les conflits faire des
médiations
on est appelé aussi dans des
associations
humanitaires pour faire des supervisions
aux professionnels voilà on est un peu
sur tous les champs en fait
ce livre c'est aussi l'occasion de
mettre des mots alors sur des mots M a u
x des maladies comme la dépression comme
le harcèlement alors ça permet de savoir
ce que c'est qu'un harcèlement alors moi
c'est pas dit clairement quand c'est du
harcèlement par exemple sur on voit
l'histoire si on lit l'histoire de
Charlotte on pourrait penser à un
harcèlement institutionnel et un
harcèlement individuel voilà
Éléonore peut-être qu'elle est en
burn-out si elle se réveille pas c'est
peut-être qu'elle est en burn out ça
personne ne m'en a parlé en tout cas des
plus de 1000 lecteurs pour l'instant
mais au début moi je me suis demandé si
si elle tombait dans les pommes parce
que justement elle avait trop travaillé
et voilà
voilà non Éléonore c'est quelqu'un qui
en veut qui se donne
beaucoup même peut-être un peu trop et
si elle a des difficultés à se réveiller
puisque personne n'arrive à dire
pourquoi ne se réveille pas c'est
peut-être que elle est épuisée
professionnellement aussi voilà du coup
ça permet de voir aussi que quand on est
beaucoup trop investi dans son travail
c'est peut-être là aussi on peut se
mettre en danger psychiquement alors
aussi à travers ce livre on suit des
histoires dramatiques de salariés
l'histoire de Charlotte histoire de
Henri qui s'est suicidé parce qu'il y
avait trop de pression au travail et ça
pour le coup ce sont des histoires
inspirées de faits réels inspiré de
faits réel et très romancée pour ne pas
que voilà en fait chacun peut
s'identifier dans chacune des histoires
puisque c'est un peu ce qu'on m'a
renvoyé comme comme retour c'est mais je
me suis reconnue un peu dans Charlotte
je me suis reconnue un peu dans Henri
moi aussi j'ai eu des idées noires moi
aussi j'ai pensé au pire voilà et puis
c'est des pères de famille des maires de
famille c'est des gens qui à côté ont
une vie mais qui à un moment donné
oublie cette vie là
et danger
et donc dans ce roman vous l'expliquez
un petit peu tout à l'heure vous mettez
un petit peu en avant le travail le
quotidien qui est fait dans cette maison
souffrance et travail comment est-ce
qu'on fait pour tenir le coup moralement
psychologiquement face à de telles
histoires
je ne sais pas
c'est un mystère c'est vraiment un
mystère bon j'écris effectivement moi je
suis une passionnée de musique dans le
dans le livre on le voit aussi puisque
Éléonore écoute beaucoup de musique
voilà c'est les moyens de cliver en fait
moi je fais de la méditation
je lis un livre très précieux tous les
matins dont je ne vous dirai pas le
titre enfin voilà je suis je suis très
spirituelle donc voilà selon vous la
situation dans les entreprises sur
l'étape psychique des salariés se
dégradent aujourd'hui
alors moi je oui je peux je peux tester
de ça puisque je vais aussi en
entreprise voilà je
j'ai pour la première fois j'ai eu droit
à un carroshi
un carroshi qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'est-ce que c'est un carrosshi un
carrossier en fait c'est quelqu'un qui
qui meurt d'épuisement au travail
parce que il y a des gens qui font des
métiers où ils sont très peu payés et
donc du coup bah ils sont obligés
d'avoir deux métiers et ils travaillent
à temps plein sur deux métiers avec très
peu d'heures de repos et et le coeur à
un moment donné lâche
donc c'est des gens qu'on a des
difficultés à réanimer voire même qu'on
ne peut pas réanimer
vous partager un peu ce constat Marianne
edwire a l'incissait que la situation
aujourd'hui sur les conditions de
travail l'état psychique des salariés au
travail se dégrade
requête directeur par exemple j'ai le
sentiment c'est vrai que depuis la covid
je pense qu'il y a un effet covid il y a
eu des retours compliqués à l'issue du
confinement il y en a qui étaient en
attente il y en a qui l'ont très mal
vécu moi j'ai des salariés à l'époque
que j'avais dû faire rapatrier parce que
en entreprise
parce que chez eux c'était l'horreur
quoi alors après c'est clair je pense à
notamment à une de mes cadres là une
personne qui voyageait à travers le
monde en non-stop qui se retrouve alors
en plus célibataire
un certain âge toute seule enfermé en
non-stop du lundi jusqu'au dimanche soir
j'ose imaginais la vie de cette femme
donc c'est vrai qu'on a rapidement on
l'a rapidement autorisé à revenir sur
site puisque nous on y était pour la
partie production donc ça derrière je
pense que c'est un impact et puis
l'impact aussi derrière nous c'est vrai
que par moment
on se dit que des fois il y a un peu de
pression et pourquoi il y a beaucoup il
y a de la pression parce qu'on a
beaucoup de commandes et on arrive par
recruter
et ce problème de recrutement on en a
parlé tout à l'heure enfin on y est
confronté tous les deux ben c'est vrai
que malheureusement au moment donné
quand vous avez de la pression
indéniablement ça se ça peut se
répercuter là-dessus
la pression au travail les gens
apprennent à la gérer
moi ce que je pointe du doigt c'est pas
tant ça en fait c'est des modes de
management délétères c'est c'est de la
maltraitance en fait et c'est pour ça
que le titre s'appelle quand l'horreur
est humaine c'est que les gens entre eux
c'est pas le travail en lui-même qui
abîme les gens bien sûr il y a des
troubles musculo squelettiques bien sûr
avoir plus mal au dos à la jambe à la
tête au bras etc mais c'est les
personnes entre elles qui en arrivent à
se faire des choses qui sont pas
tolérables en fait je pense que si
effectivement on se regardait un peu
mieux si on se respecte plus si on
respectait un peu les ses coutumes si on
ne serait-ce que de dire bonjour au
revoir merci s'il te plaît tu as fait du
bon boulot aujourd'hui je t'en remercie
enfin c'est basique mais c'est essentiel
pour moi ce genre de choses voyez la
petite pause café où on va prendre un
café de manière tout à fait informelle
et on va se donner des informations
informelles qui sont essentielles pour
la bonne continuité du travail tout ça
là ça s'oublie dans le travail et
aujourd'hui c'est j'en parlais tout à
l'heure on a parlé tout à l'heure au
ministère de la santé c'est c'est pas
parce qu'on va mettre une petite salle
de repos pour les soignants que les
soignants vont s'autoriser à aller dans
la petite salle de repos parce que ils
ont quand même d'autres choses à faire
c'est à dire qu'il y a une perf à poser
il y a un soin à donner voilà et dans
des conditions plutôt tendues on va pas
se le cacher et bien merci beaucoup
Françoise François d'avoir répondu je
vous remercie à nos questions je vous
invite à lire ce livre quand l'horreur
est humaine il n'est disponible sur le
site internet de la maison souffrance et
travail 78 qui s'affiche en bas votre
écran mais également sur tout autre
plateforme si vous souhaitez le
commander on poursuit dans la
littérature samedi dernier avait lieu la
remise du prix du livre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de prix ont
été décernés dans les catégories
jeunesse et adultes au programme
également de cette après-midi table
ronde et dédicaces les 5 continents on
peut échanger avec leur hauteur favoris
le reportage de Gabriel Gontier une
journée d'échange et de partage autour
de la lecture samedi 1er avril avait
lieu la remise du prix du livre de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines Daniel Picouly
président du jury nous explique
l'intérêt autour de ce salon c'est
surtout aussi les auteurs qui étaient là
les prix qui sont remis l'implication
j'aime beaucoup l'idée d'une implication
des médiathèques de d'un vote par
internet et tout ça c'est ça qui est
important ça veut dire que toute la
ville est un peu parti prenante de ces
prix dans la catégorie les visionnaires
évoquant des questions du monde de
demain c'est le dernier des siens de
Sybille Grimbert sur l'extinction qui a
été récompensée par les lecteurs je
rêvassais comme ça un jour autour du
dodo et je me disais c'est dingue
d'avoir été le dernier dodo d'avoir
commencé avec des semblables et avoir
terminé tout seul comme tout le monde je
crois que comme la sixième extinction
est un bruit de fond dans lequel on est
qu'on entend tout le temps enfin c'est
normal et c'est très bien j'étais pas
insensible à ce sujet les élèves de 5e
de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines ont
sélectionné l'auteur du prix lire et
choisir dans cette catégorie Julia
billet l'emporte avec l'ouvrage la
guerre de Catherine c'est une jeune une
jeune adolescente qui est juive qui qui
est à la maison des enfants qui a un
lieu qui accueille des enfants en début
de la guerre et en 42 quand la rade du
Vél' d'Hiv est annoncé la directrice de
l'école décide de faire partir tous les
enfants juifs ça va être le récit de son
de son grand voyage de son périple au
travers de la guerre l'événement était
organ isé par le réseau de médiathèque
de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines en
partenariat avec la radio marmite FM et
les librairies du pavé du canal et du
pavé dans la mare une cinquantaine de
petits et grands lecteurs étaient réunis
pour cette deuxième édition qui ne
devrait pas être la dernière
et nous avons été rejoint un plateau par
Véronique Ithurbide bonsoir bonsoir
Mathilde vous allez bien ça va merci à
vous ça va merci alors comme d'habitude
le mardi vous venez nous présenter vos
informations insolites qui ont pu
échapper au regard des îles à moi de
quoi est-ce que vous allez nous parler
alors je vais vous parler la librairie
la suite qui propose deux animations
pour enfants et pas que dont par exemple
un photomaton poésie je vous expliquerai
tout à l'heure après une conférence qui
a lieu samedi prochain qui s'appelle le
patrimoine oublier en Vallée de
Chevreuse on va parler d'urbex je vous
expliquerai tout à l'heure et après et
ben je vais faire ma pub et je vais vous
parler de deux VIP qu'on a enregistré
mercredi dernier
un peu un peu longue et bien
c'est un format un peu long format un
peu long pour bien rentrer dans les
détails donc ce sera tout à l'heure
restez bien avec nous nous avons été
aussi rejoint en plateau par Julien de
nerveau bonsoir bonsoir alors après les
jolies soirées cinéma et concerts le
concept lancé par l'association jolie
prod reviens avec un trait du mot une
première jolie soirée humour et au
programme ce samedi 8 avril au Théâtre
de 50 ans en Yvelines alors Julien
deverno vous êtes vice-président à la
direction artistique de l'association
jolie prod et au menu de la soirée 6
humoristes quel est le concept des
jolies soirées est-ce que vous pouvez
nous l'expliquer oui alors le concept
des jolies soirées c'est de créer une
synergie entre le triptyque acteur
culturels locaux donc les salles du
territoire les artistes les talents
émergents du territoire et les habitants
de proposer un spectacle de qualité et
à proximité de chez soi voilà
dire dans les salles qui qui sont là et
qui font des spectacles tout là toute
l'année et là allez découvrir des
talents peut-être un peu moins connus
encore pour les faire connaître ça c'est
le concept des jolies soirées vous
l'avez dit il y a eu du cinéma où là on
est en avant des réalisateurs locaux des
acteurs locaux on a eu des concerts avec
des groupes des chanteurs et là ça se
passe sur une thématique autour de
l'humour parce qu'on a envie de rire
tous ensemble on a besoin de rire et
c'était une volonté du président de
l'association Olivier Salazar depuis la
création des soirées d'aller sur cette
thématique d'humour ça se monte pas
comme ça un plateau de stand-up on a
appris pas mal de choses et donc là on
est au Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et on va
ramener cette cet art là sur cette scène
nationale c'est pour cette raison que
vous avez voulu un peu élargir et faire
cette soirée jolie soirée humour pour
quelle raison pour justement je sais
plus ce que vous m'avez dit mais élargir
et pas seulement parler de cinéma et de
concert parce qu'on a plein d'autres
thématiques comme par exemple une
thématique ou encore une soirée magie
c'est des choses qu'on désarme qu'on a
envie d'exploiter et de mettre en avant
les talents de notre territoire sur ces
disciplines là sur ces arts là et donc
là le stand-up ça s'y prêtait il y avait
la volonté du théâtre aussi d'amener
cette cet art sur sa scène et nous la
volonté de le faire on a trouvé cette
synergie on l'a fait et on a trouvé les
artistes qui avaient besoin de
s'exprimer sur une scène des artistes du
coin c'est parce que le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines regorge de
talent humoristiques alors Jamel
Debbouze
un autre sa mère la liste est longue le
réservoir est inépuisable
qui sont très connues très médiatisés
c'est aussi ça la volonté de l'iprod
c'est d'aller chercher des gens qui sont
peu médiatisés et ont besoin de se faire
connaître pour pour vivre de cet art là
parce que ils ont autant de talents et
donc c'est important d'aller
promouvoir ses talents là et promouvoir
la sur local c'est ça l'essence de notre
association c'est aussi de créer
d'accompagner développer des projets
artistiques il y a toute cette promotion
et il y a toute cette volonté de mettre
en réseau des amateurs et des
professionnels et donc sur les jolies
soirées le résultat il y a alors
justement on va parler d'eux il y aura 6
humoristes du coup Sofiane et tahit
Sarah boujdi Alex CLEMI Deluxe Alexandra
feignez et Mathieu Delage alors dans les
grandes lignes qui sont-ils et pourquoi
ce sont eux qui ont été sélectionnés
j'ai envie de dire alors pourquoi ce
sont eux étaient sélectionnés il y a un
comité de sélection sur sur joli prod on
a reçu pas mal de candidatures on a
sélectionné
parmi les personnes qui faisaient un peu
plus rire avec toutes des critères de
notation comme à chaque fois on fait
avec le les soirées cinéma quand on doit
choisir des courts métrages c'est
toujours pareil il y a toujours un
comité de sélection donc voilà ça on se
réunit entre entre artistes de
l'association pour
pour étudier cette programmation il n'y
a pas une personne qui décide et ensuite
ce sont des personnes qui ont un lien
avec le territoire ou avec les Yvelines
comme par exemple Matthieu Delage qui
était originaire des
longs pas ou Alexandra feignez du côté
de Trappes on a un peu plus loin on a
aussi clinique et Deluxe qui est de
Marly-le-Roi voilà donc j'en ai plein
j'ai pris tout en tête mais globalement
l'idée c'est ça c'est d'avoir cet
ancrage ici dans les Yvelines et d'avoir
un spectacle ensuite de qualité et de
promouvoir des talents qui qui doivent
l'être et peut-être que demain il y aura
d'autres talents dans une autre jolie
soirée humour qui sait déjà testons avec
la première parce que comme je disais on
a appris beaucoup de choses avec tous
ces scènes de peur où les gens qu'on a
rencontré qui montent des plateaux
d'humour on a appris beaucoup de choses
sur le stand-up parce que ça se fait pas
comme ça c'est pas ah bah je connais lui
il fait rire ouais elle fait elle fait
rire ou c'est un peu son travail non il
y a des codes qu'on a pas comme par
exemple l'animation de la soirée
en général nous on prend notre charge et
là c'est Sofiane vous en parliez qui lui
va être le M6 la soirée pour mettre le
public dans le mood stand-up ça vous
donne envie d'y aller
j'aimerais beaucoup y aller voilà
il y a pas de problème samedi et grand
plaisir oui je trouve que on a la chance
d'avoir sur le territoire des très
belles salles et une grosse
programmation de tout enfin des petites
ou des grandes salles comme celle du
théâtre donc je trouve ça chouette c'est
dynamique c'est vrai que c'est une
opportunité pour nous que de travailler
avec la scène nationale parce que dans
quand je dis on met en avant des acteurs
culturels on a travaillé avec le grenier
à sel à trappe ou avec le cratère à
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines ou la salle de
la tour avec métassos un voisin de
Bretonneux là on est sur la scène
nationale avec le concert qui a eu en
novembre et là cette soirée humour que
ces acteurs là nous ouvrent les portes
ça permet aussi au bénévoles de
l'association qui font un travail
remarquable cette soirée ça fait un an
qu'elle se travaille en off
ça permet à ces gens-là aussi de vivre
des moments inoubliables et uniques et
culturelle pour lequel qui fait vie
point c'est des moments qui font vibrer
ces bénévoles et aujourd'hui je pense
c'est important de les remercier tous
Voilà et de remercier aussi
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour son
soutien sur sur ces soirées-là
je me disiez à l'instant il reste
quelques places encore quelques places
vous pouvez y aller c'est sur le site
joli prod fr il y a la billetterie
il y a des places et 10 euros ça se
passe à partir de 20h30 et à la fin la
particularité c'est que vous pouvez
rencontrer les artistes après la soirée
c'est toujours le concept il y a
toujours cette notion de rencontre et
d'échange avec la salle et la Seine
voilà
tout dit merci beaucoup Julien de
narvault d'avoir répondu à nos questions
on va maintenant parler de démo je ne
sais pas si ça vous évoque quelque chose
c'est un projet créé par la Philharmonie
de Paris en 2010 l'objectif rendre la
musique accessible à tous c'est dans ce
cadre que 90 élèves de 50 ans en
Yvelines et de Chanteloup-les-Vignes ont
reçu des instruments de musique en
janvier dernier après plusieurs mois
d'apprentissage ils se sont réunis pour
une première grande répétition le
reportage de Julien Leroy et Michael
elneau les alto violoncelles
contrebasses tout ce groupe là fait la
même chose ok mais c'est là-bas les
violons
tous les violons
journée de répétition ce mercredi à la
Commanderie d'Élancourt 90 enfants âgés
de 5 à 11 ans sont venus s'entraîner
avec leur nouveaux instruments donnés en
janvier dernier dans le cadre du projet
demos l'objectif ce jour-là est
d'observer les progrès de ses apprentis
musiciens
oui on passe du bruit à un certain
manières de manier l'instrument de le de
faire un son un petit peu plus stable
que juste faire n'importe quoi quand on
débute en fait
les progrès en fait on les voit assez
vite à avancer des progrès rapides qui
ont permis à ces enfants venus de 50 ans
en Yvelines et de Chanteloup-les-Vignes
de tomber sous le charme de cet univers
musical je pense ça très bien et j'aime
bien l'instrument que je fais je sais je
vais le rameau
je sais jouer un petit peu la cumbia
je crois que c'est tout les nouveaux
musiciens se produiront avec leurs
nouveaux instruments lors d'un concert
exceptionnel le 28 juin à la Meurice de
Trappes encadrée par des professionnels
rattachés la Philharmonie de Paris ses
apprentis apprennent depuis des semaines
à jouer trois pièces pour ce spectacle
dont une création collective c'est un
peu comme faire de la cuisine avec les
ingrédients qu'on a donc voilà
aujourd'hui j'avais tel ingrédient tel
ingrédient qu'est-ce qu'on va faire et
puis voilà on a le but c'est de faire un
plat avec avec ce qui nous tombe sous la
main et ça c'est très exaltant parce que
du coup on est sûr c'est comme si on
travaillait sur mesure avec eux d'ici la
fin de l'année ces jeunes feront trois
répétitions de groupes afin de peaufiner
tous les détails pour présenter au
public un spectacle à la hauteur de leur
investissement
c'est un peu à un incontournable des
visites culturelles à faire dans les
Yvelines ou même en Île-de-France plus
largement le parc France Miniature ouvre
ses portes ce samedi 8 avril pour en
parler avec nous Marianne alors je le
répète vous êtes la responsable
communication du site située à Élancourt
et avant de commencer j'aimerais faire
un petit tour de plateau est-ce que vous
êtes déjà rendu à France Miniature oui
moi j'emmenais mes enfants il y a très
longtemps
en revanche j'ai oui dire que France
Miniature était implantée à Élancourt si
je me trompe pas mais qu'elle est en
cours n'était pas représentée dans
France Miniature est-ce que c'est vrai
ce que c'est faux
dans tous les villages de France il y a
un petit monument il suffit de chercher
c'est vrai que par contre on n'a pas
représenté Élancourt
la particularité du parc c'est qu'on a
représenté tous les monuments ou un 30e
donc pour pour vous présenter puisque
vous l'avez pas visité encore mais je
vais vous renvoyer une invitation et
également oui
on a vraiment représenté sur cinq
hectares en forme de carte de France un
grand jardin en forme de carte de France
117 monuments qui sont au 1/30 donc on a
une tour Eiffel qui fait 10 mètres on a
un château de Chambord qui fait à peu
près un mètre 50 le château de
Versailles qui s'étend sur plus de 150
m² au sol avec les jardins et les
bâtiments et France Miniature c'est
vraiment une balade à faire qu'on soit
grand ou petit on va tous piocher des
choses différentes des souvenirs ou des
envies de découverte aussi beaucoup de
magistes c'est très ludique il y a des
petits trains qui circulent on découvre
de région en région tout ce qu'il y a de
plus joli de connus ou de reconnu et
vraiment je vous invite à venir nous
voir à partir de ce samedi puisqu'on
réouvre ce samedi oui vous rouvrir en
grande pompe si j'ose dire puisque vous
allez ouvrir avec un monumental jeu de
piste à l'occasion bah du weekend de
Pâques c'est Pâques et pour pas que on
aime bien chasser les œufs donc on a
conçu un parcours pour les familles qui
a un parcours d'observation on va pas
proposer à nous visiteurs de de rentrer
dans les maquettes mais simplement de
faire une balade et d'observer au détour
des allées des monuments et des mises en
scène des petits œufs factices qu'on a
caché des petits sujets lapins pouls etc
on leur raconte une petite histoire de
Pâques on fournit à tous nos visiteurs
quand ils arrivent un petit livret dans
lequel il va falloir repérer des indices
tout au long du parcours et à la fin de
la visite si on a bien tout trouvé même
si on n'a pas tout trouvé on récupère
des petites récompenses qui sont elles
vraiment chocolatées il y aura quand
même des vrais chocolats à déguster ça
vous donne peut-être envie je vais
retourner avec vos enfants que c'était
soit un petit peu grand pour sa journée
donc ça va faire en famille plutôt en
famille on a aussi beaucoup d'adultes
qui viennent seuls se balader pour
découvrir les monuments et le patrimoine
quand on est avec des petits-enfants il
y a aussi tout un tas de petites
attractions et de lieu d'interaction où
on peut jouer avec le paysage on va
apprendre comment fonctionne une écluse
par exemple on va pouvoir manipuler les
vitraux de la cathédrale de Chartres
avec un gros puzzle en 3D qui est à
l'extérieur de la maquette donc ce qu'on
a voulu proposer à nos visiteurs c'est
vraiment d'aller du nord au sud des
tests en ouest de voir tout le parcours
toute la carte de France mais en
s'amusant et on permettant aux petits de
aussi découvrir des choses dans les
régions et de pas être simplement
spectateurs oui c'est ce qui fait aussi
un peu l'ADN de France Miniature c'est
de proposer des attractions et puis des
expériences
interactives on a Fort Boyard depuis
l'année dernière on a Koh-Lanta c'est ce
qui fait un peu la l'identité de France
Miniature alors on a voulu aussi salut
le patrimoine télévisuel avec ces deux
grosses émissions qui réunissent
beaucoup les familles qui sont des
emblématiques et puis qu'on des valeurs
de du défi du challenge du jeu avec
Koh-Lanta l'année dernière on a souhaité
proposer quelque chose de rafraîchissant
avec une zone aqualudique l'idée c'est
vraiment de proposer à nos visiteurs
quand ils viennent à France Miniature de
de passer du bon temps ensemble
d'échanger de partager et souvent quand
on passe du bon moment bah c'est en
riant beaucoup
en découvrant en apprenant et adultes
qu'on soit maman ou mamie on a toujours
plaisir à transmettre et à raconter des
histoires aussi à notre entourage donc
c'est ce qu'on fait à France Miniature
alors ça vous a donné envie d'y aller
pour aller retrouver le lapin de Pâques
peut-être
alors votre monument français miniature
si vous deviez en choisir un dans le
parc c'est lequel c'est la question
difficile celle-là puisque je j'en aime
beaucoup je dois dire qu'il y en a un
que j'ai eu envie d'aller voir en vrai
il y a pas très très longtemps ça doit
faire trois quatre ans j'ai organisé mes
vacances dans cette région pour le voir
en vrai c'est la cathédrale
Sainte-Cécile d'Albi dans le Tarn qui
est une cathédrale qui est colossale
majestueuse en brique rouge et qui est
très grosse en maquette dans le parc et
j'avais très envie de l'avoir en vrai
donc celle-ci c'est un joli souvenir
mais j'en ai plein alors hormis ce jeu
de piste sur pack et sur cette chasse
aux œufs est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
actualités à venir à France Miniature
alors on vous dévoilera la semaine
prochaine une nouveauté qu'on est en
train de finaliser ça va être un
parcours immersif sur le thème de la
France des légendes où on va proposer à
nos visiteurs de s'égarer quelque part
dans la forêt de Brocéliande et de
rencontrer des des créatures et des
personnages avec pas toujours de très
bonnes intentions on sera guidés par la
méchante fémorgane dans cette aventure
et on vous en dit plus la semaine
prochaine et bien on a hâte de découvrir
tout ça merci beaucoup Marianne d'avoir
été avec nous en plateau pour répondre à
nos questions alors pour rappel la
réouverture du parc France Miniature
c'est ce samedi 8 avril à 10h vous
retrouverez plus d'informations sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
votre écran alors comme chaque mardi
c'est l'heure de passer aux insolites de
Véronique vous êtes prêtes je suis prête
allons-y allez c'est parti
alors Véronique on commence cette
chronique avec quelque chose d'insolite
forcément puisque c'est si j'ai bien
compris un photomaton qui parle mais
c'est encore plus que ça alors ça se
passe où ça se passe à Versailles c'est
la librairie la suite une librairie
indépendant qui est tenu par Lucile
depuis 12 ans qui vient d'emménager
d'ailleurs pour info rue du bayage
quartier des antiquaires voilà et elle
propose deux animations alors la
première c'est samedi qui vient samedi 8
avril un atelier créatif avec une
artiste Roxane qui va proposer aux
enfants de créer une carte de Pâques
complètement créative créer une carte
créative c'est joli comme expression
bref elle apporte tout le matériel c'est
sur inscription c'est payant et après on
ressort avec une belle création
tous les énormément créatif bon mais
surtout moi ce qui m'a le plus amusé
personnellement c'est le samedi d'après
samedi 15 avril vous avez un photomaton
poésie alors ils vont construire un
photomaton un faux alors vous vous
rentrez d'un côté et de l'autre côté il
y aura trois comédiens enfin peut-être
pas les trois en même temps il va te
serrer trois comédiens ou trois voix
bien différentes aux âges bien
différents vous rentrez d'un photomaton
et vous choisissez une émotion alors
guetter joie tristesse scolaire etc et
c'est comédiens vont sélectionner un
poème en fonction de l'émotion que vous
avez souhaité et vont vous le lire ils
sont cachés c'est un peu comme un
confessionnal HP ça vous parle on est
c'est caché la personne de le prêt
derrière on voit pas et bah là c'est
pareil vous les verrez pas les comédiens
et ils vont vous réciter un poème alors
je trouve ça génial cette idée et après
vous repartez avec votre poème imprimé
et on va vous faire découvrir donc des
il y aura des problèmes pour les enfants
des poèmes pour les adultes c'est à
partir du primaire c'est une professeure
de lettres dans les Yvelines qui a eu
cette idée elle s'appelle Pia vectène et
elle a sélectionné des poèmes 19e 20e
pas forcément très connu on va
évidemment 21 on va sortir des
Baudelaire et des la fontaine c'est donc
d'autres poésie et le but c'est quoi
c'est de rendre attractive la poésie de
la désacraliser de de nous
accessible voilà à tous les âges la
rendre vivante et qu'on oublie un peu
nos a priori et voir qu'il y a des
jeunes auteurs que c'est très prolifique
et que ça vaut le coup de d'aller voir
du côté de la poésie voilà parce que ça
vous crée une émotion vous voulez un
poème rien que pour vous et pour vos
beaux yeux alors ça c'est pas mal non
première information insolite direction
maintenance Saint-Rémy Chevreuse pour
retrouver le patrimoine oublié voilà
alors c'est samedi 8 l'après-midi à
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse c'est organisé
par la mairie de Saint-Rémy de 14 à
17h30 et c'est une conférence en fait
qui s'appelle le patrimoine oublié au
valet de Chevreuse il y a donc la
conférence une expression de photos et
des projections de vidéos alors en
dessous il y a clé de l'abandon à la
restauration voilà est-ce que vous savez
ce que c'est que l'UR
c'est de l'art dans la rue c'est pas
envie de vous contredire mais pas tout à
fait ok
je me dois être diplôme
alors l'urbex c'est l'exploration
urbaine alors voilà donc Thomas Alix
c'était c'est un évier noir qui a grandi
à Gilles sur Yvette et petit déjà à 8
ans il faisait durbex sans le savoir
pourquoi parce qu'au bout de sa rue il y
avait une maison abandonnée et qu'avec
ses copains ils allaient explorer
c'était trop magique après il y avait un
manoir hanté salmanoir hanté sur le
chemin de l'école après il y avait les
grands frères qui faisaient des fêtes
des squats un peu interdit bien
évidemment dans des lieux comme ça
complètement désaffectés il a eu ce goût
faux ces lieux il voulait savoir quel
était leur histoire pourquoi ils étaient
restés comme ça figés dans le temps à
l'abandon à qui c'était qu'elle était
l'histoire etc alors il en a même fait
des un documentaires qui a été repéré
par Arte sur Internet et qui est qui est
passé et après il en a fait un deuxième
qui est passé sur France 3 il y a pas
très longtemps qui s'appelle enquête
d'urbex voilà et là ma troisième
documentaire lui est commandé par France
3 donc voilà donc ce monsieur il va être
là il va nous parler de ces lieux de la
valise On a moins qu'avant bien sûr mais
il y en a encore il est accompagné par
Grégory passieur Grégory passieu c'est
un personne qui travaille dans
l'immobilier et qui est passionnée de de
château et il a acheté un château à
restaurer un château qui s'appelle le
château d'Artois qui est aux
Essarts-le-Roi du 16e et il était envoyé
par la mérule la mérule c'est un
champignon horrible quand vous avez de
la méoude chez vous
donc lui il a dû parce que ça se met
dans le bois et c'est très très
compliqué à retirer donc il a fait tout
ce qu'il fallait au bout de 5 ans il a
réussi à sauver ce château il est il est
restauré et maintenant faut qu'il en
trouve un autre bon mais alors ces deux
messieurs Thomas Alix et Grégory passieu
pour monter une association qui
s'appelle sauvetage du patrimoine donc
ils vont vous la présenter samedi 8
avril à Saint-Rémy et ils espèrent avoir
beaucoup d'adhérents et leur idée ce
serait de comment dire de peut-être
acquérir un lieu abandonné le restaurer
avec des subventions etc et en faire un
lieu vivant un lieu de centre culturel
un centre médical et même des
habitations enfin redonner vie à ces
lieux qui qui sont à protéger à
restaurer à faire revivre quoi tout
simplement et et voilà je crois que je
vous ai tout dit sur sur ça voilà on le
voit ça s'afficher à l'écran ce sera
samedi 8 avril du coup à partir de 14h
un mot peut-être pour terminer sur vos
deux interviews vous devez alors on a
enregistré deux VIP cette semaine un
avec Arthur Arthur Loisel c'est un
acteur auteur un jeune yvelinois qui a
27 ans et qui a deux spectacles à
l'affiche enfin un one man non un seul
en scène pardon la seule en scène qui va
être le 7 et 8 ou 8 et 9 je sais plus 7
et 8 avril et un autre spectacle qui est
plus en continu qui s'appelle le
coffrage à jouer perdu funambule à Paris
et donc cette Arthur Loisel ce qui est
je trouvais assez rigolo c'est depuis
qu'il a 6 ans il fait il a fait de
l'impro des six ans pendant 10 ans ça
vous parle d'un projet j'imagine et puis
il a jamais lâché et aujourd'hui il est
donc auteur de différents spectacles et
acteurs moi je trouve c'est une belle
histoire et le deuxième invité que j'ai
eu envie c'est Axel Charles messans qui
est aussi un évidence qui est
journaliste reportait d'image il a
commencé sa carrière pour en faisant des
sujets toujours un peu extrême parce que
ce qu'il aime c'est c'est quand c'est
excitant quand c'est vraiment l'extrême
les les champions au top du top les
situations
qui font l'adrénaline bravo merci c'est
moi que je cherche et voilà il a aussi
effet beaucoup de sujets sur des lieux
de conflits et donc fort de cette
expérience
pas TF1 la contacter l'a embauché donc
il est couvre depuis le mois de juin
l'Ukraine voilà et donc ce qui est
intéressant je trouve c'est de voir
comment l'envers du décor comment on
travaille quand on est une équipe one
France comment on quel lieu sur quel
lieu on va comment on y va comment on
rencontre la population les militaires
la ligne de front enfin voilà ne vous en
parle un peu plus en détail quoi
complètement très longuement quand vous
avez dit et bien merci beaucoup
Véronique pour vous Mathilde on vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine comme
d'habitude ce sera avec plaisir plaisir
partagé c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission mais juste avant de se quitter
je vous propose de jeter un dernier coup
d'oeil à la météo de demain
le soleil s'impose dans les Yvelines de
matin le ciel sera dégagé sur l'ensemble
du département au niveau des
températures il fera froid compter 2
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie aux dents et
Rambouillet et 3 degrés à Versailles
dans l'après-midi le soleil continuera
de briller mais les températures
resteront fraîches il fera 12 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Versailles et 13
degrés à Houdan et Rambouillet et c'est
la fin de cette émission merci pour
votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]